Does DC's 'The Flash' get a gold medal?
Or does this long-awaited movie limp across
the finish line?
Here's what the first reviews have to say
about 'The Flash.'
"Let's get nuts."
Few films can claim to have the kind of press
as "The Flash" in the lead-up to its release.
After spending years in development hell,
the movie finally started making progress
with director Andy Muschietti at the helm
and starring Ezra Miller as the Scarlet Speedster.
However, Miller's well-documented instances
of criminal behavior have tainted what was
otherwise a highly anticipated movie.
It's especially dire considering that the
film was meant to set up the future of the
DC live-action cinematic universe, which will
soon have James Gunn and Peter Safran at the
steering wheel.
Warner Bros. and DC have downplayed Miller's
involvement and instead focused on how this
could be one of the greatest superhero movies
ever made.
Everyone from Tom Cruise to Stephen King got
early screenings and raved about "The Flash"
to anyone who would listen.
Such reviews, combined with the return of
Michael Keaton as Batman, certainly makes
the film an enticing prospect, even to people
who haven't necessarily been following DC's
latest cinematic outings.
But the question remains: how good is "The
Flash" really?
Does it live up to the hype, or was it all
a marketing tactic?
At first look, it seems as though "The Flash"
certainly isn't without its merits.
It's currently standing at a 72% positive
rating on Rotten Tomatoes with 53 reviews
as of the making of this video.
Many critics praise Ezra Miller's performance
as well as strong turns from actors new and
old to DC's universe.
Ben Affleck gets time to shine as Batman before
Michael Keaton takes over those duties in
an alternate timeline.
But cameos aside, it seems as though critics
have really taken to the emotional story beats
that make up "The Flash."
The film draws heavily from the "Flashpoint"
storyline in the comics, where Flash travels
back in time to save his mother, only to create
an alternate timeline.
The same happens in the movie, and the underlying
story of Barry Allen trying to find his place
as a superhero while maintaining his family
gives the film some much-needed weight.
Brandon Zachary of CBR writes,
"The Flash is a surprisingly emotional film,
exploring concepts like the inevitability
of mortality even in a world of limitless
potential.
The consistent undercurrent of grief and loss
keeps the stakes high."
It's these moments that apparently help the
movie stand up on its own two feet, even during
more questionable moments.
David Rooney of The Hollywood Reporter suggests
"The Flash" isn't perfect.
Still, that core concept helps carry it through.
According to the critic,
"If 'The Flash' ultimately proves uneven,
its wobbly climactic showdown far less interesting
than the more character-driven buildup, the
story's core of a young man struggling to
reconcile with the loss of his mother carries
it through."
Interestingly, a film billed as the second
coming of superhero movies has more to offer
when it's focused more on characters than
spectacle, and the audience's enjoyment of
such grander moments may vary.
Without getting into spoilers, "The Flash"
seemingly does… a lot.
There's time travel, alternate timelines,
and different versions of the same superheroes,
including some surprising cameos.
The movie wants to have its cake and eat it,
too, but many critics think the film stumbles
more often than it flies.
"There may not be a future."
In Ross Bonaime's review for Collider, there's
praise for certain story elements, but ultimately,
this is a film that's unable to stand on its
own two feet.
The critic concluded,
"Unfortunately, this isn't a story that holds
together on a narrative level.
Cameos and fan service are fine to have, but
the story has to be there to back them up,
and it's not quite there with 'The Flash.'"
There's little doubt certain cameos may be
enough to make general audiences forgive some
of the movie's poorer moments, but critics
are seeing right through them, especially
as the film drags on.
Like so many big action movies before it,
"The Flash" ends with a CGI-laden final battle
that critics are already panning.
One negative take came from Peter Bradshaw
of The Guardian, who wrote:
"Despite some diverting touches, Miller's
smirking, gurning, mugging doppelganger performance
is a trial and in any case gets lost in the
inevitable third-act CGI battle apocalypse,
which is weightlessly free of jeopardy and,
like the rest of the film, does not exactly
go by in a flash."
There's a wide range of opinions, with some
thinking the film's one of the best superhero
flicks of the 21st century, while others view
it as another DC letdown.
And coming out on the heels of the nearly
universally-acclaimed "Spider-Man: Across
the Spider-Verse" may not help matters, either.
People can make up their own minds when "The
Flash" comes out on June 16.